bonsoir et bienvenue dans savouregard au
sommaire ce soir on poursuit notre bilan
de cette première année de la nouvelle
Assemblée vu par les présidents de
groupe avec ce soir André Chassaigne
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes le président du
groupe GDR qui réunit les députés
communistes mais aussi certains députés
ultramarins et vous allez donc nous
livrer votre regard sur cette nouvelle
législature mais aussi sur les en 1 les
1 an de la nuque avec ses succès et ces
quelques tensions depuis un an et avant
cela dans la première partie de Ça vous
regarde on va on a voulu donner la
parole aux élus des territoires qui ont
été touchés par les émeutes de ces
derniers jours en France alors
qu'Emmanuel Macron recevait aujourd'hui
à l'Élysée plus de 240 mers paroles
d'élus donc pour raconter ces violences
pour poser leur diagnostic et proposer
des réponses aux nombreuses questions
que cette crise soulève enfin vous
retrouverez nos affranchis pour leur
parti pris et puis Bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée Quentin
lobby se fait épingler par les députés
voilà pour le programme est-ce que vous
êtes prêts tout à fait prêt et là on y
va excusez-moi
[Musique]
le chef de l'État a donc voulu entendre
ceux qui ont vécu cette vague de
violence sur le terrain plus de 240 mers
ont été reçus à l'Élysée cet après-midi
ils ont tous été touché d'une façon ou
d'une autre par ses émeutes comment
ont-ils vécu ces violences quelle
réponse attentive du gouvernement de
tout cela ont débat avec nos invités ce
soir avec notamment Mathieu Lefebvre
bonsoir vous êtes députés renaissance du
Val-de-Marne avec nous également Sophie
Taillet paulian vous êtes députés
écologiste de ce même département
Thomas ménager bonsoir vous êtes
rassemblement national du Loiret et
notamment de la ville de Montargis dont
on a beaucoup parlé parce qu'elle a été
particulièrement touchée par ses émeutes
enfin Alexandre Vincent des bonsoir vous
êtes député les républicains du Rhône
notamment votre circonscription couvre
la ville de Vaulx-en-Velin et puis bien
sûr notre grand témoin André Chassaigne
vous intervenez quand vous le souhaitez
dans ce grand débat mais d'abord pour
commencer le chrono de Blacko
bonsoir Stéphane histoire Clément
bonsoir à toutes et tous alors vous avez
vous avez 200 secondes pour nous aider à
me à mieux comprendre la situation alors
ne perdons pas tant on a tous remarqué
depuis le début de la semaine il y a
comme progressivement début de retour au
calme un peu partout en France donc
c'est le retour du débat politique et
notamment à l'assemblée avant de parler
de l'Assemblée on note que le Président
vous l'avez dit c'est un premier acte
politique ce matin en recevant plus de
240 mères et qui ont des maires des
communes qui ont été touchées par les
émeutes il avait fait un autre geste
hier soir BFM télé était là pour le
filmer c'est rendu donc dans une caserne
du 17e arrondissement siège de la BAC
nuit à Paris pour apporter son soutien
policier dont je vous rappelle 700 ont
été blessés pendant les années retour
donc à l'Assemblée cet après-midi avec
un point de vue complètement opposé à
celui du président quand il soutient les
policiers celui des insoumis qui lisent
n'oublions pas que si des émeutes ont
éclatés en France c'est bien parce que
un policier a tué un jeune des quartiers
pour un refus d'obtempérer donc pour
éviter que ça se reproduise ce que dit
Mathilde de panneaux il faut modifier la
loi abroger la loi de 2017 qui avait été
voté sous Bernard Cazeneuve à Matignon
et qui fixe les conditions lesquelles un
policier peut tirer en cadre
fidotempéries on écoute Mathilde Paname
vous m'avez dit hier les émeutes que
connaît le pays n'ont rien à voir avec
la mort de Naël pire vous voulez faire
peser sur nous la responsabilité de la
colère quand elle prend racine dans un
meurtre odieux êtes-vous oui ou non
favorable à l'abrogation du permis de
tuer de la loi Cazeneuve qui a provoqué
l'explosion du nombre de morts en cas de
refus d'obtempérer non on va pas traîner
je vous fais écouter dans la foulée la
réponse de la première ministre qui a eu
l'occasion de dire tout le mal qu'elle
pensait de l'attitude des insoumis
pendant ce week-end en répétant en
martenant même plusieurs fois qu'ils
étaient sortis du champ républicain on
écoute la conclusion de son intervention
les violences madame la Présidente
panneaux rien ne peut les excuser et
pendant que vous jetez de l'huile sur le
feu pendant que vous donnez des excuses
au délinquant nous nous sommes engagés
pour rétablir l'ordre républicain et la
justice ne vient jamais de la violence
je vous remercie donc il y a eu le
moment où l'extrême gauche selon que
dénoncer les violences policières de
l'autre côté de l'hémistique plutôt à
l'extrême droite cette fois-ci on a fait
par ses préoccupations en disant mais
l'immigration a quand même un rôle dans
les émeutes qui se sont déroulés ces
derniers jours on écoute donc Michael
taverne qui a un député lui du Nord un
député RN évidemment
face à ces prédateurs barbares qui
défilent autorité de l'État crache sur
la France et violent des élus a conçu
sursaut sécuritaire pour soutenir les
forces de l'ordre dans leur mission à
quand ce sur ce politique pour expulser
les délinquants étrangers alors il a des
bornes étaient très en forme elle a
répondu quasiment à toutes les questions
sauf que là elle a laissé répondre donc
Gérald Darmanin sur la question de
l'immigration Gérald Darmanin dont je
vous rappelle que le second prénom est
Moussa en honneur à son grand-père
algérien en l'écoute la question
d'aujourd'hui c'est ce des jeunes
délinquants pas des étrangers nous
sommes nombreux ici Monsieur le Député
être issu des quartiers à être issus
d'immigration et à aimer notre pays et
nous ne voulons ni de la haine des
policiers ni de la haine des étrangers
mais nous voulons de l'amour de la
République bon voilà vous avez une
petite idée pardon de la teneur des
débats à l'Assemblée vous avez que le
gouvernement a cherché à rendre coup
pour coup aux attaques de l'opposition
mais de mon côté je voudrais sortir un
peu de la polémique et pour ça laissez
la conclusion au groupe communiste alors
je ne dis pas ça parce que le Président
chassagnelage je tenterai de fayoter il
se trouve simplement que il y a un
député communiste qui s'appelle Stéphane
peu qui est député de la
Seine-Saint-Denis qui cet après-midi ce
matin pardon était interrogé sur LCP et
qui faisait référence un rapport qui a
été publié en 2018 qui s'appelle le
rapport Cornu gentille du nom d'un élu
LR donc voilà d'un seul coup les
communistes qui arrivent à s'entendre
avec les républicains sur un sujet un
début d'entente d'unité nationale qui
sait on écoute ce que Stéphane peut
ressortait de ce rapport
le rapport parlementaire sur la
Seine-Saint-Denis de 2018 avait
objectivé le fait que ces quartiers
populaires dans notre pays avaient moins
de République moins d'enseignants moins
de policiers moins de magistrats
et que au contraire la promesse
d'égalité républicaine n'était pas au
rendez-vous bon voilà j'ai essayé de
faire bref de laisser la parole avant
tout aux élus peut-être que les LLR ont
été mal serré il faudrait peut-être
commencer par Monsieur Vincent en tout
cas il y a tellement de choses à dire
que je vous laisse débattre merci
beaucoup Stéphane dacoski alors je vais
pas commencer par vous je suis désolé
monsieur Alexandre vincendez je voulais
d'abord avoir une rapide réaction de
tous les deux élus de la Nupe aux
attaques lancées par Elisabeth borne il
en a parlé Stéphane blackkowski attaque
contre elle et fille accusée d'être
sortie du champ républicain pour avoir
refusé d'appeler au calme refusé de
condamner les violences des émeutiers
André Chassaigne est-ce que ça vous a
dérangé vous l'attitude des défis
je me suis
accès à ce qui se passait dans mon
groupe par le bancaire je suis pas là
pour apporter des appréciations sur les
propos qu'ils ont tenu par EFI c'est
vrai qu'on peut avoir des approches
différentes on a des accroches
différentes je dis pas que la cohésion
se retrouve sur tous les sujets mais je
pense que en ce qui nous concernant des
très clair très net il faut s'opposer à
toutes les violences il faut faire
preuve une grande sévérité mais pas
seulement pas seulement j'aurais
peut-être raison de le dire durant cette
émission pas seulement en direction des
jeunes de ces adolescents qui ont commis
toutes ces dégradations ce qui est
absolument inacceptable et c'est vrai
qu'il faut des jugements très sévères à
leur rencontre mais aussi tenir compte
de toutes les causes qui peuvent y avoir
tirant ce n'est pas un sac sur la tête
et je crois que le gouvernement s'est
après midi a montré qu'il se mettait un
sac sur la tête qui l'affrontait pas les
vrais problèmes Sophie taillé polluant
ne pas condamner les violences c'est
sortir du champ républicain comme le dit
Elizabeth borne moi ce qui m'a vraiment
choquée dans ce dans ce moment aux
questions d'actualité c'est que Mathilde
panot je pose un certain nombre de
proposition et on aurait aimé avoir par
exemple la vie de la première ministre
sur cette loi de 2017 sur la situation
de la des liens entre la police et la
population il y a eu un sondage là qui
montrait qu'il y avait à peu près un
tiers des Français qui qui posaient pour
lesquelles le rapport à la police posé
posé problème c'est quand même pas rien
et au lieu de faire son devoir
c'est-à-dire de répondre aux questions
des parlementaires en fait elle a fait
la meilleure défense étant l'attaque
elle a elle a attaqué la LFI mais c'est
pas ça
qu'on attend on attend du gouvernement
qui pose des problèmes des réponses
politiques à la crise qui est
actuellement à l'oeuvre après
des écolos et s'il y a des problèmes
dans le pays c'est de la faute et elle
est fibon tout ça voilà moi j'ai appelé
au calme je l'ai fait très rapidement
parce que je considérais que c'était que
c'était pas une situation qui permettait
de en fait de répondre à la douleur de
cette famille et à la question posée par
ce qu'on a vu dans cette vidéo à savoir
les violences policières qui existent
dans notre pays faut arrêter le déni et
aussi le sentiment de ségrégation
sociale spatiale et de d'humiliation de
discrimination vécues dans ces quartiers
qui sont les problèmes auxquels on a
aujourd'hui
nécessité de répondre bon alors voilà
pour la polémique politique de la
journée j'aimerais maintenant vous
entendre vous sur ce que vous avez vécu
sur vos territoires vos circonscriptions
qui ont toutes été touchées par les
émeutes Alexandre vincentet vous avez
été maire de Rillieux-la-Pape pendant 8
ans votre circonscription comprend aussi
les villes de Vaulx-en-Velin de Bron
voilà sont des communes qui ont connu
des tensions vivent par le passé quel
regard ce que vous portez sur ce que
vous avez vécu là ces derniers jours
est-ce que c'est différent alors au
niveau national ce qui est arrivé c'est
différent des émeutes de 2005 il y a pas
de parallèle à faire mais chez bonne et
simple raison alors ce qu'on a vu ces
derniers jours moi j'étais sur le
terrain je dis soir il y avait conseil
municipal à Rillieux j'y siège avec
l'ensemble de l'équipe municipale et les
émeutes ont commencé ensuite ils se sont
attaqués à Rillieux-la-Pape à la
médiathèque qui est flambant neuve au
plein cœur des quartiers que que j'avais
lancé il y a quelques années en arrière
j'essaie de crèche un bâtiment de
service à Vaulx-en-Velin j'ai Hélène
Geoffroy le lendemain Paris ils ont
essayé de laquelle la médiathèque et la
construit en plein cœur des quartiers à
Bron on a brûlé des transports en commun
la soirée de jeudi était très dure on a
attaquer plusieurs fois le poste de
police municipal à Rillieux-la-Pape le
jeudi et le et le vendredi soir et on a
commencé à avoir une accalmie à partir
de à partir de samedi le vrai sujet de
la premièrement moi je tiens quand même
à saluer le travail des forces de
l'ordre franchement les policiers
municipaux à Rillieux-la-Pape et dans
les autres communes à Bron et avoir en
Velin les policiers nationaux les
pompiers moi je n'ose même pas imaginer
ce que beaucoup il est de bon temps chez
certains de critiquer le travail des
policiers honnêtement s'il n'est pas nos
policiers sur le terrain je n'ose même
pas imaginer ce qui se serait passé par
contre au-delà de ça bien sûr qu'il faut
combattre ces violences là qui sont
inacceptables on s'attaque pas au
symbole de la République on s'attaque
pas à des bâtiments publics et quand
j'entends dire que dans les quartiers de
feriens ce n'est pas vrai s'il y a une
médiathèque qui était brûlée en plein
cœur en tout cas on a essayé de la
brûler en plein cœur des quartiers de
Rillieux-la-Pape c'est parce qu'on a
voulu construire une médiathèque c'est
parce qu'on construit des on va on va
parler de tout ce qui a été fait pour
les banlieues de cette politique de la
ville des quartiers mis en place des
années c'est pas les habitants des
quartiers qui se sont révoltés c'est les
voyous qui ont essayé de faire trembler
la République parce que quand la
miniature qui était attaquée c'est des
habitants de Rieux qui sont venus nous
soutenir et c'est des enfants des
quartiers qui sont venus mettre sur les
palissades le lendemain des dessins pour
dire ne touchez pas notre médiathèque et
ça c'est vraiment ce qui m'a ému Mathieu
Lefebvre vous vous êtes élu du
Val-de-Marne plusieurs voilà violence ou
éclatés dans différentes villes de votre
circonscription est-ce que vous aviez vu
venir les choses est-ce que il y avait
des signaux annonciateurs de ça non bien
sûr que non d'ailleurs il y a des villes
qui n'avaient pas au peu connu de
violence que ma Bry-sur-Marne les
policiers municipaux ont été attaqués à
Nogent-sur-Marne c'est un collège et des
policiers municipaux qui ont été
attaqués on ne s'y attend évidemment
jamais et c'est comme le disait monsieur
Vincent del le profil de ces jeunes
c'est très jeune qui sont son prix au
symbole de l'autorité à
Champigny-sur-Marne qui est une ville
qui connaît parfois des flambées de
violence la police a été attaquée il y a
eu des voitures qui ont été brûlées moi
comme Monsieur Vincent des je veux
redire tout mon soutien à la police
municipale et à la police nationale qui
ont fait preuve d'un sang-froid
extraordinaire et on l'a vu plus
largement dans le département du
Val-de-Marne avec Madame taipoliant
département a subi une flambée de
violence à Fresnes les agents de la
pénitentiaire étaient au péril de leur
vie ces violences-là elles doivent être
unanimement condamnés et ça passe par la
réarticulation d'un discours républicain
sur l'autorité et sur toute forme
d'autorité que ce soit le policier le
pompier le gendarme mais aussi le maître
d'école il faut qu'on arrive à
réarticuler ce discours et pour cela les
politiques ont une responsabilité qui
est une responsabilité absolue Sophie
tayet polluant vous êtes un peu voisin
on perd d'élection chez vous je crois
que c'est du côté de Cachan qui était
compliqué
toutes les villes de ma
circonscriptions alors moi s'il y en a
que
à qui je souhaite donner tout mon
soutien et remercier très
chaleureusement ce sont d'abord les mers
que j'ai eu au téléphone tous les matins
plusieurs fois dans la journée parce
qu'ils ont vraiment été ils ont vraiment
été là pour essayer de faire au mieux
quand dans la première nuit on avait
pas assez de force de l'ordre pour
réagir à la situation faut quand même
faut quand même le dire et aussi aux
pompiers qui qui ont eu vraiment forte à
faire et leur adresse vraiment tout mon
soutien après moi ce dont je me souviens
enfin ce qui m'a marqué c'est une mère
de ma circonscription qui me raconte que
pendant que des personnes s'introduisent
dans l'âme dans sa mairie pour la
saccager
un de ces élus enfant de la ville leur
mais arrêtez quelque part c'est qui sait
les connexes mais arrêtez arrêtez mais
c'est fatas on est là on est vos élus
pardon j'ai dit sans nous
on est vos élus et en fait il y a il y a
une forme de de de
je dirais de déchaînements et de qui qui
rend plus possible le dialogue alors
même que il s'agit pas
là pour ces personnes de
personnes avec des casiers judiciaires
moi j'entends beaucoup délinquants
voyous ce qu'on observe dans les
comparutions c'est quand même aussi
beaucoup de personnes qui en fait voilà
pris dans la logique des des événements
c'est tout à fait regrettable et c'est
condamnable et je le condamne mais se
retrouve en situation voilà de de
commettre des choses qu'il n'aurait
certainement jamais dû connaître moi
c'est ça que je retiendrai aussi parce
que il y a là un débordement et pour moi
c'est c'est il faut vraiment
s'interroger si on en reste à se
dévoiler et puis c'est vrai que c'est
pas la majorité c'est pas la majorité
des jeunes c'est pas la majorité des
habitants et des habitants de nos
quartiers qui sont sortis et qui ont ce
sont livrés à ces débordements de
violence encore une fois je condamne
mais mais cela dit cela parle de la
situation dans nos quartiers moi j'en
suis désolé cette éruption là oui malgré
tout je la Redoute depuis de longs mois
quand au moment du plan de relance on a
crié au secours en disant il faut un
milliard pour nos cités pour nos
banlieues on va parler des moyens des
moyens qui ont été débloqués jusqu'à
présent pour la politique de la ville de
ce qui a été fait de ce qu'il reste à
faire Thomas ménager on a tous en tête
les images de la ville de Montargis avec
ces deux immeubles qui ont été ravagés
par les flammes dans une ville de
province plutôt calme jusqu'à présent
qui avait échappé à ce type de violence
comment vous expliquez cela oui très
clairement nous en 2005 avait eu
absolument rien à Montargis c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est de voir que en
2005 ça avait touché quelques grandes
agglomérations mais les villes moyennes
comme Montargis étaient protégées il y
avait des signes avant-coureurs des
signes encore liés déjà au manque de
force de l'ordre parce que si le premier
soir le soir où il y a eu ces trois
immeubles qui ont été incendies avec des
personnes des familles avec des bébés
qui étaient à l'étage on est passé à
deux doigts du drame parce que les
policiers et les pompiers ne pouvaient
pas intervenir les policiers étaient
dans l'incapacité d'assurer leur
sécurité il y avait déjà une montée
croissante de la de la délinquance sur
notre territoire il y avait besoin
d'effectifs de police supplémentaires
depuis un certain nombre d'années après
moi ce qui m'a profondément choquée je
suis allé à la rencontre des policiers
c'est l'âge c'est-à-dire de voir les
jeunes garder à vue de voir des jeunes
qui n'ont pas compris qu'ils étaient en
style de garde à vue mais ils ne
comprenaient pas la portée de leurs
actes il ne comprenaient pas
le poids que doit représenter
normalement d'être mis en garde à vue et
aussi un certain nombre de parents qui
venaient récupérer leurs enfants en
engueulant les policiers en disant que
leurs enfants étaient pas au bon endroit
au bon moment alors ça a été il y a une
partie de délinquance endémie qu'il y a
dans un salon de quartier et mais il y a
eu un effet d'entre eux un effet
d'entraînement sur un certain nombre de
jeunes mais je pense que ce n'est pas en
répétant tout le temps que l'État ne
fait rien pour eux alors qu'il y a eu
des milliards de versets que l'État
serait de manière totalement
structurelle raciste que il y aurait une
police qui tue qu'on participe à donner
à ces jeunes l'envie de croire en la
République et c'est ça aussi je pense
qu'on tient à une part de responsabilité
une partie des politiques qui ne partent
de responsabilité dans ce qui s'est
passé on va on va se pencher à présent
sur ce qui s'est dit cet après-midi dans
la réunion à l'Elysée entre Emmanuel
Macron et ses 240 mères qui ont été
touchés par des violences qu'attendait
ses mères qu'elles engagements Emmanuel
Macron a-t-il pris devant eux élément de
réponse avec Maïté Frémont accompagné de
Pierre Michael Carniel et Clément
Perrault
une loi d'urgence sur la construction
on est tous confrontés un peu à la même
situation grande ville petite ville
ville moyenne ville de province on voit
bien que c'est un phénomène quand même
assez unique auquel on est on est
confronté maintenant il s'est diffusé
des difficultés dans nos villes qui ne
sont plus l'apanage de banlieue de
quelques banlieues
au bout des trois heures le président de
la République n'a strictement rien dit
il nous a simplement écouté mais encore
une fois j'étais pas venu à une thérapie
de groupe j'étais pas venu voir
l'infirmière scolaire voilà et
malheureusement aujourd'hui c'est le
sentiment que j'ai ressenti cela voilà
on va se mettre au travail ensemble et
on va essayer de corriger les
erreurs du passé le Président nous
rassemblant a voulu faire oublier que
depuis des mois il a refusé toutes les
demandes de rendez-vous formulées par
les maires de banlieue toutes les
alertes toutes les tribunes le
thermomètre a indiqué que la fièvre
montait et que ça allait exploser mais
le docteur a refusé de voir
je suis déjà un vieux de la vieille
quand j'étais gamin il y avait des cours
de morale alors là il y a les cours
d'éducation civile je sais pas il faut
qu'on arrive absolument à ce qui se
réencre sur des principes à pas la Chine
si jamais ils retrouvent le rapport
Borlo qui n'hésite pas à le sortir il y
a quand même pas mal de choses qu'il
avait demandé qui ont été proposées qui
sont assez en phase avec et ce que la
droite et ce que la gauche peut attendre
sur un certain nombre de quartiers alors
bien sûr il y a une ou deux mesures du
rapport qui ont été mis en place mais il
y en a beaucoup qui ont pas été mis en
place
voilà pour ces paroles de merde
recueillies également par Emma Chalas
Mathieu Lefebvre on sent quand même
certains maires agacé par la situation
pas besoin de thérapie de groupe dit
l'un d'entre eux comme s'ils avaient le
sentiment que on les a un peu laissés de
côté pendant des années et qu'on
découvre la situation au moment où la
cocotte minute explose je pense qu'il
faut pas avoir de polémique politique
leur n'est pas à cela il faut être à la
hauteur du moment j'ai vu même
d'ailleurs que certains mères avaient
refusé de se rendre à la vitesse du
président de la République ça n'est pas
à la hauteur de la crise que nous vivons
mais surtout ce que je voudrais dire à
ces mères c'est le soutien et le soutien
absolu de l'État mais ceux qui avaient
des solutions qu'il les trouvent après
la crise c'est un petit peu facile il
n'y a pas de solution toute faite pour
répondre à des problèmes aussi
structurels que ceux que ce plan Borlo
qui a été un peu balayé d'un revers de
main par Emmanuel Macron
Bordeaux c'est lui qui a doublé les
crédits pour la rénovation urbaine chez
moi à Champigny-sur-Marne il y a toute
une cité qui va être rénovée grâce au
crédit de la rénovation
urbaine évidemment on peut toujours
faire mieux on peut toujours aller plus
loin mais vous savez je suis pas certain
que des milliards répondent à des jeunes
qui vont voler des Nike dans un magasin
dans le fond ces jeunes là ils sont pas
en crise de sens ce sont des voyous et
des délinquants et quelque part ne pas
répondre à cette question sécuritaire
c'est aussi jeter le propre sur
l'ensemble de nos jeunes de banlieue il
y a aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de
jeunes de banlieues qui sont dans une
situation extrêmement difficile dans des
cités enclavées qui sont précaires mais
je crois que si on ne répond pas d'abord
de façon sécuritaire à cette dérive à
ces actes qui sont absolument
incalifiables on y arrivera pas André
Chassagne la seule annonce qui a été
faite par Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui
c'est cette loi d'urgence pour
reconstruire au plus vite tout ce qui a
été détruit c'est forcément l'attente à
court terme de tout le monde et a
commencé par les maires eux-mêmes est-ce
que vous attendiez qu'il aille au-delà
dès aujourd'hui qu'il lance des
chantiers prioritaires et si oui
lesquels d'abord ce que je veux dire
c'est un peu facile de dire
l'unique responsabilité l'unique
responsabilité serait celle des jeunes
de ces jeunes qui ont commis tous ces
violences toutes ces dégradations c'est
quand même le signe d'une crise d'une
crise grave dans notre société et ça
j'ai le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui on veut
pas en parler moi j'ai des témoignages
des témoignages qui viennent des luttes
ma sensibilité politique ou d'autres pas
les témoignages des lieux de ma
circonscription il y a pas eu de
problème sur le circonscription que je
représente mais notamment dans mon
groupe des témoignages de députés de la
Seine-Saint-Denis il y a Stephen peut
notamment
qui m'ont dit quoi ils m'ont dit il y a
véritablement une fracture qui est
réelle donc faut bien prendre ces
questions à bras le corps et c'est vrai
ils ont fait le constat que y compris
dans des communes où il y avait eu des
actions de politique de la ville où il y
a un développement associatif où il y a
des mères qui font un travail
remarquable avec avec au niveau du sport
au niveau de la culture au que même là
il y a eu des problèmes mais c'est par
exemple pour autant
ne disons pas qu'on a foutu des
milliards en l'air comme je l'ai écouté
hier dit à Matignon par certains
porte-parole de groupe on peut pas dire
ça et comment on voit bien qu'il y a une
dégradation on voit bien que les
dégradation de la situation il y a une
fracture qui va prendre après le corps
et on a le sentiment aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement alors vous allez dire
peut-être que c'est trop tôt mais on a
le sentiment aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement ne prend pas bras le corps
les questions qui se posent et qui dit
c'est des voyous c'est des voyous qu'on
fait ça non n'en restons pas à se sentir
mannequin j'écoute le garde des sceaux
notamment et d'autres dire les parents
n'ont pas fait leur boulot les parents
ne sont pas la hauteur mais moi je pense
je pense à des à des femmes seules des
familles monoportentales qui ont
plusieurs enfants qui n'y arrivent pas
et pour autant qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
on va considérer que ce sont elles qui
sont responsables la situation parce que
elles auraient dans leur famille des
voyous les choses il faut les prendre
avec je parle avec beaucoup plus de
d'analyses sans a priori idéologique
parce qu'il y a des solutions à apporter
mais ça veut dire que par exemple sur la
question de l'autorité parentale que
faut-il faire quand une mère de famille
et débordé par la situation l'école
parce que quand un masque
j'ai pas terminé comme Stéphane peut
l'as dit cet après-midi il y a une
dégradation considérable au niveau des
écoles où il y a pas un enseignant qui
veut qui veut aller enseigner
aujourd'hui en Seine-Saint-Denis il
cherche à partir il y a aujourd'hui on a
recruté des professeurs des écoles qui
dans l'épreuve ont obtenu 5 sur 20 alors
que dans les autres départements de
France on recrues des professeurs des
écoles et qui dans les profs qui ont
beaucoup plus et on dit ce que vous
savez
laisser
réagir à ce que vous dites ce que je
veux dire par là il y a des problèmes
réels au niveau de l'éducation c'est
vrai qu'au niveau de l'éducation
populaire aussi il faut qu'on fasse
davantage faut qu'on prenne un bras le
corps toutes ces questions mais quand je
contacte pas de dire ce sont des voyous
sur la question de l'autorité parentale
vous vouliez réagir mais surtout ces
sujets là la politique David moi je ne
jamais dire j'étais maire de banlieue je
continuais très vite mon lieu d'ailleurs
je vais pour ceux qui nous regardent et
qui ne connaissent pas mon parcours je
suis j'ai été ce qu'on appelle un
parachuté j'ai choisi de me présenter
dans une commune de banlieue en 2014 où
je n'étais pas né où je n'avais pas
grandi parce que j'estime que c'est ici
que les défis demain et d'aujourd'hui
sont on a lancé un des plus grands plans
de rénovation urbaine de la métropole de
Lyon si ce n'est plus grand 380 millions
d'euros on est en train de refaire les
écoles on est en train de créer de la
mixité sociale le vrai sujet c'est quoi
c'est que ça ne va pas assez vite et on
a laissé se développer sur notre
territoire de véritables ghetto on a en
fait aussi une question on a enfermé
l'éthique tourné vers la rénovation
urbaine et peut-être pas suffisamment
sur l'humain l'encadrement des jeunes
sur le terrain par exemple dans un
quartier vous refaites des écoles à neuf
vous mettez des nouveaux équipements
vous construisez un cinéma une
médiathèque des équipements sportifs
vous refaites les équipements publics
mais derrière l'urbain il y a de
l'humain parce que derrière ces grandes
rénovations quand vous créez de la
mixité sociale vous démolissez un
quartier 100% logement sociaux où vous
avez mis ensemble toutes les personnes
qui sont en difficulté et souvent issus
de l'immigration parce qu'on est bien
content de et on veut pas qu'elle se
mélangent avec les autres c'est ça le
vrai sujet quand on crée de la mixité ça
fonctionne ça c'est un de mes combats
mais au-delà de ça ça veut dire que vous
devez mettre derrière des vrais
politiques publiques il faut revoir la
politique de la ville avec des contrats
d'objectifs et arrêter le saupoudrage ça
veut dire que derrière quand ça marche
on amplifie quand ça ne marche pas on
supprime et on revit et de l'autre côté
je l'ai dit je l'ai dit à Matignon et je
l'ai dit à l'Elysée il faut aller
beaucoup plus vite dans l'exécution
l'argent il est là il faut pas il en
faut plus vite et mieux parce que le
moment vous prenez une décision on a
envie d'entendre un peu ce côté du
plateau Sophie taipoliant d'abord vous
lire et agir sur la question de
l'autorité parentale je rappelle tout de
même ce qui a été dit par Elizabeth
borne aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée
les sanctions pénales vont tomber pour
les familles qui laissent leurs enfants
participer à ses émeutes leurs enfants
âgés de 12 13 14 ans avec des amandes
avec des stages de responsabilité
parentale je j'ai pu la formule exacte
les communes et notamment leur donnant
des moyens pour mettre en place des
services publics locaux par exemple de
maison des parents ça ce sont des choses
qui peuvent fonctionner mais qui ont
aujourd'hui des budgets
mais bien sûr aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que
on va on va on va encore plus mettre la
tête sous l'eau de gens qui sont déjà en
grande difficulté donc c'est pas ça le
sujet aujourd'hui c'est pas ça
aujourd'hui notre problématique elle est
elle est elle est assez simple je crois
il y a sur le fronton de nos mairies
marqué liberté
égalité
fraternité moi je crois qu'il y a au
moins deux éléments qui sont au fronton
de mon mairie qui pour une certaine
partie de la population qui vivent dans
des quartiers de ségrégation de
relégation le sentiment que l'égalité
n'est pas là et la fraternité non plus
parce que quand on entend sans arrêt des
discours qui sont de plus en plus
stigmatisants on l'a on la voit pas donc
il y a des politiques d'égalité et c'est
pas seulement en refaisant en mettant de
l'argent mais je jamais justifié de
brûler quelconque crèche mais monsieur
excusez-moi mais si on vous avait
contrôlé cinq fois par semaine pendant
toute votre jeunesse
de l'excuse
pas une question
qui vivent ça mais justement je vous
invite à sortir du déni et avoir la
réalité en face et ce ne sont pas
seulement des élucubrations des Ludo
gauche se sont ainsi des travaux
très pointus de chercheurs de sociologue
qui observent la situation dans les
quartiers et ce sentiment de relégation
ce n'est pas qu'une idée en l'air c'est
un vécu très douloureux et c'est cela
que vous ne voulez pas voir vous ne
voulez pas le voir mais il faut le voir
et il faut y apporter
quelle est la mise en place pour que ce
mot ne soit pas qu'un mot qui soit vécu
comme un 20 mots Thomas ménager sur
cette question évoquée par Sophie
tailler paulian il y a une vraie
défiance d'une partie des habitants de
ces quartiers chez les jeunes notamment
qui ne se reconnaissent pas ou plus dans
les valeurs de la République et qui
n'ont pas forcément le reconnaissait pas
hein ils aimeraient bien
intégrés pleinement dans la communauté
nationale peut-être vous voyez il la
vivent pas comme une réalité voilà c'est
pas qu'il y a des rêves
[Musique]
le rassemblement national presque
apporter à cela moi je vous dis ce qui
me gêne aujourd'hui c'est une culture de
l'excuse c'est à dire que c'est pas
parce qu'on est dans un milieu modeste
on a un milieu même très populaire qu'on
devient un délinquant moi quand la
génération de mes parents moi mes
grands-parents à 10 12 13 14 ans on
était à la maison au lit prêt à se
brosser les dents à un moment il faut
quand même responsabiliser les parents
il y a des enfants de classe populaire
de classe moyenne il y a des enfants
de parents qui n'ont pas de boulot qui
vivent du RSA qui vivent du chômage mais
qui ne sont pas des délinquants à un
moment il faut arrêter d'excuser un
certain nombre de parents ce n'est pas
aussi donc la mère de famille
célibataire qui travaille avec des
horaires de nuit qui arrive pas à finir
ses enfants sanctionner et bien figer
une amende il y a toujours il y a
toujours des gauches il y a toujours des
exceptions mais dans les quartiers
populaires on monte jusqu'à 40% de
famille monoparentales c'est une réalité
quand même importante
j'ai des tas d'amis qui ont été élevés
par des femmes seules qui avaient des
horaires décalés qui étaient infirmières
qui étaient aide-soignantes qui étaient
fan de ménage et qui ne sont pas devenus
des délinquants et pareil au niveau des
moyens moi je dis pas que c'est de
l'argent mis en l'air il y en a eu
beaucoup de mi avec beaucoup de choses
qui n'ont pas porté leurs fruits comme
quoi ce n'est pas qu'une question de
moyens bien entendu il y a des problèmes
de mixité il y a un problème qui a des
questions d'éducation mais moi ce qui
m'inquiète aussi et je vous dis madame
ça m'inquiète quand vous donnez le
sentiment que l'État serait raciste que
l'État serait contre ces jeunes je je
vois moi des jeunes dans les quartiers
populaires de ma circonscription qui
était les premiers à être en colère en
disant nous on a tout fait pour s'en
sortir c'était pas simple mais c'était
pas simple dans le dernier village et
voir leurs équipements publics brûlés
après les enfants aussi pas aussi égaux
que les autres parce qu'ils n'ont jamais
d'origine marocaine d'origine turque
pleinement français de mauvaise qualité
parce qu'ils sont dans des dans des
établissements
étrangères
personne
généralité madame vous entend plus on ne
vous entend plus et vous vous dites que
ces gens-là en 2018
j'ai pris une mesure s'il vous plaît à
l'époque qui avait fait beaucoup parler
c'était la possibilité de convoquer les
parents de mineurs délinquants et s'il
n'acceptait pas le suivi on a construit
en même temps une maison de la famille
et de la parentalité c'est de pouvoir
s'il n'a pas la main qu'on leur tendait
pour eux et leurs enfants qui naient de
commettre des premiers fêtes délinquance
je n'acceptaient pas c'est la
possibilité de suspendre les aides
municipales pour un an résultat des
courses en l'espace de quelques années
on a convoqué une cinquantaine de
familles sur l'ensemble de ces familles
il n'y en a que quelques-unes qui ont
refusé la main tendue parce que ses
parents là étaient démissionnaires ne
voulaient pas s'occuper de leurs enfants
très clairement il les couvrait mais ça
c'est une ultra minorité l'immense
majorité quand vous leur dites attention
si vous ne vous aidez pas à refaire
venir votre enfant dans le droit chemin
donc assurer son avenir on supprimera
pour un an les adminicipales vous savez
quoi il venait autour de la table on en
discutait et on arrivait à travailler
avec la famille et avec le gamin et au
bout du compte et au bout du compte moi
ces enfants je les retrouve parce qu'on
a mis en place des soirées de la
réussite dans ma commune on les retrouve
quelques années après où ils ont réussi
parce qu'on les a aidés je pense que
d'un côté
aussi aux parents leur responsabilité et
ce n'est pas parce qu'on fait partie des
classes modestes qu'on ne sait pas de
s'occuper de leurs enfants le dire ou
comme le fait une partie de la gauche
j'aimerais qu'on la question de la
police
j'aimerais entendre Mathieu Lefebvre sur
la question de la police notamment la
police de proximité en tout cas
partie de la République s'il vous plaît
la police de sécurité du quotidien
c'était un engagement d'Emmanuel Macron
2017 il n'a pas été tenu à ce jour
est-ce qu'il faut tenir cet engagement
aujourd'hui pour rétablir un lien de
confiance entre la police et une partie
de la population d'abord président de la
République il a mis plus que n'importe
quel autre président de la République le
paquet et les moyens sur la pollution
d'un côté 10000 policiers gendarmes
depuis 2017 on a mis une paquet sur la
formation on a mis le paquet sur le
matériel il faut poursuivre et c'est le
sens de la loi de l'orientation qui a
fait adopter le ministre de l'Intérieur
maintenant moi je crois qu'on doit aussi
chacun retrouver le sens des
responsabilités il faut éviter les
discours qui sont susceptibles de porter
atteinte à l'image de la police quand on
dit que la police tue ça n'est pas de
nature à restaurer l'autorité de l'État
et à restaurer l'autorité de la on ne
doit pas avoir peur de la police on ne
doit pas la craindre évidemment mais on
doit être dans une situation de
déférence à l'endroit de la police donc
la police de sécurité du quotidien c'est
pas pour demain vous c'est pas pertinent
pour voir les quartiers prioritaires de
la politique de la ville des moyens
considérable ont été déployés et
évidemment vous avez pas vu Madame
Patate parce que vous n'y allez
peut-être pas hors de question
évidemment de les retirer très bien
c'est la fin de ce débat qui a été un
peu agité j'en conviens mais qui a
permis quand même d'avancer sur pas mal
de questions merci à tous d'être venu
sur le plateau de savouard dans quelques
instants ce sera autour de nos
affranchis ils sont prêts ils sont là
Richard Verly on verra avec vous le
regard de la presse étrangère sur les
émeutes en France Cécilia gabizon vous
évoquerez la fin de la discrimination
positive dans les universités
américaines décisions de la Cour suprême
des États-Unis et puis Stéphanie
Despierres ce soir dans Bourbon Express
vous ne parlez de quoi Stéphanie je vais
vous parler du lobby des pesticides qui
est sur la sellette ici à l'Assemblée
parfait à tout à l'heure à tous les
trois place à présent à notre grand
témoin André Chassaigne président du
groupe GDR Gauche démocrate et
républicaine merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation nous avons donc déjà reçu
plusieurs présidents de groupe pour
faire le bilan de cette première année
de la nouvelle législature que faut-il
retenir de votre action et de celle du
groupe GDR depuis un an ici à
l'Assemblée on voit cela avec Hélène
Bonduelle
si on vous invite André Chassaigne ce
que vous êtes à la tête d'un petit
groupe au sein d'une large alliance la
nupesse 12 députés communistes et 10
ultramarins qui forment la Gauche
démocrate et républicaine alors avec un
groupe de 22 députés seulement vous le
savez pour se faire entendre il faut se
faire remarquer ça tombe bien vous qui
êtes député depuis 21 ans vous n'avez
pas votre langue dans la poche
essayé de m'exprimer en toute franchise
je ne fais pas de cinéma
alors pas question de baisser la voix
quand les débats n'avancent pas comme
vous voulez comme lors de la niche
parlementaire de vos collègues de
liottes et leur proposition de loi pour
abroger la réforme des retraites
jamais a été actionné c'est dire à quel
point aujourd'hui vous abîmez vous
écrabouillez la démocratie parlementaire
une voix qui tonne un franc-parlé certes
mais pas un n'importe quel prix les
sorties de route des insoumis vous
agacent et l'une d'elles à l'encontre du
ministre du soft vous fait sortir de vos
politiques vous êtes un imposteur et un
assassin
je me sens blessé même humilié je le dis
le débat démocratique c'est un échange
d'idées c'est pas un échange d'insultes
et vos idées vous les faites avancer
quitte à vous démarquer de vos alliés de
la nuit Pesse le groupe GDR est ainsi le
seul à voter pour le projet de loi sur
la relance du nucléaire un thème qui a
souvent alimenté vos divisions cette
année un mariage avec des soubresauts
mais pour l'instant pas de divorce
dans la majorité derrière vous crie de
colère on reconnaît votre travail
constructif et votre volonté d'agir au
point que la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale vous verrez bien ministre de
l'Agriculture alors André Chassaigne
nous avons une question pour vous après
44 ans d'engagement politique
seriez-vous prêt à entrer dans un
gouvernement d'union nationale
alors André chassen je vous pose la
question oui ou non je voudrais d'abord
savoir quelle est la définition du nom
national s'il y avait véritablement un
risque pour la nation aujourd'hui le
contexte ne s'y prête pas la situation
bien sûr que non de la France
je l'ai dit hier d'ailleurs à Matignon
la difficulté d'un élu comme moi
qui a toujours été dans l'opposition
c'est d'être un peu comme ces critiques
littéraires qui mettent encore les
poèmes écrits par les autres ou qui sont
par rapport à des ouvrages qui ont été
écrits et qui en fait n'écrivent jamais
produisent rien donc pour moi la vie
politique notamment à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est essayer d'être utile
s'essayer de faire avancer des textes de
lois comme je l'ai fait lors du mandat
précédent avec les retraites où je me
suis beaucoup battu mais ça ça existe de
rassembler mais c'est on peut pas
envisager que je suis puisse rentrer
aujourd'hui dans un gouvernement
soi-disant d'une nationale mais pour
conduire quelle politique et je crois
que mon utilité elle est beaucoup plus
forte dans une opposition qui s'appuie
sur la culture parlementaire qui est
celle des communistes où on est sur un
texte on essaie de faire bouger on
essaie d'apporter des amendements on
apporte des éclaircissements et on ouvre
aussi des des perspectives politiques
différentes alors on vient de voir le
groupe GDR a globalement voté à
l'unisson du reste de la nu sauf sur
cette question du nucléaire là où il y a
un désaccord en revanche c'est sur la
stratégie d'opposition de la nuque on a
revu votre coup de gueule quand ce
député elle est avec qualifié Olivier du
soft d'assassin cette stratégie d'élé
ficelle du bruit et de la fureur pour
reprendre l'expression de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon elle vous pose problème à vous
aujourd'hui elle me pose problème dans
la mesure on a cette inter-groupe les
quatre groupes qui constituent donc la
nups à l'Assemblée nationale mais nous
avons notre autonomie note indépendance
la règle qui est celle en particulier du
groupe la gauche de brouette
républicaine que je peux que je préside
c'est défendre nos idées portées nos
propositions quand on peut se retrouver
avec les autres groupes d'opposition
pour faire passer des amendements pour
faire passer des textes bien évidemment
on regarde l'intérêt général mais pour
autant pour autant on a une culture
différente qui est qui est effectivement
sur certains points à l'opposé de la
façon de faire de la France insoumise
donc il s'agit pas de copier la France
insoumise il s'agit de rester ce que
l'on est mais si vous deviez mettre un
vœu pour l'en deux on vous adressant à
LFI ce serait quoi la fin de la
bordélisation des débats je leur dirai
je leur dirai tout simplement essayer de
faire bouger les lignes essayons de
profiter du fait qu'il y a pas d'une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui comme c'était le cas lors de
la du premier mandat d'Emmanuel Macron
essayons d'être plus utile que l'on est
et pour être utile pour être utile c'est
pas invociférant qu'on arrive à avoir
des résultats même si ça peut être
relayé par les réseaux sociaux ça fait
plaisir à certains moi je pense qu'en
étant quelquefois plus discret on peut
aussi on peut aussi faire avancer des
choses au-delà de la stratégie de LFI
vous vous en êtes à votre cinquième
mandat à l'Assemblée qu'est-ce que vous
inspire le climat d'ensemble qui règne
dans cette nouvelle Assemblée là depuis
un an asse majorité absolue
climat dans l'hémicycle tendu et même
parfois dans les couloirs de l'Assemblée
ça peut arriver je dirais que c'est on a
la une occasion manquée l'occasion
manquée c'est que les élections
législatives c'est vrai on répondit à
une atteinte en termes de résultats qui
était celle de du peuple de France c'est
faire en sorte que l'Assemblée nationale
puisse remplir toutes ces fonctions que
le pouvoir législatif puisse s'exercer
dans le cas d'une séparation des
pouvoirs et ce que je reproche à la
majorité relative actuelle et ce que je
reproche au gouvernement ce que je
reproche au président de la République
c'est de n'avoir pas accepter qu'il
puisse sortir de l'Assemblée nationale
des textes avec lesquels ils sont pas
d'accord et ça on a assisté depuis un an
à
un avalement si je peux parler de cette
façon du pouvoir législatif c'est-à-dire
de ce qui revient au Parlement par
l'exécutif l'exécutif ne peut pas
supporter que sorte du Parlement des
textes avec laquelle ils sont pas
d'accord c'est donc un déni démocratie
j'ai parlé j'ai repris le terme de 11
avant l'heure qui disait de démocratures
c'est ça aujourd'hui des termes très dur
ce mélange de démocratie de dictature
pour vous dès que son qu'on s'oppose à
ce que veut faire
l'exécutif et bien on utilise tout ce
qui est peut y avoir de plus régressif
dans la Constitution on l'a vu mais ce
sont les règles ce sont les règles elles
sont constitution n'ont jamais été
cumulés comme elles sont aujourd'hui on
a eu par le passé l'usage du 49 c'est
une forme de violence politique mais il
y a une violence qui s'exerce à
l'Assemblée nationale dès que un texte
par exemple peut passer et qui
correspond pas à la volonté de la
majorité actuelle et ben on va chercher
l'article de la Constitution on le
mettra à côté d'un autre et on fait une
espèce de bouillie de tout ce qui peut y
avoir de plus rétrograde de plus
régressif dans la Constitution pour
éviter que pour les châtives puissent
exercer j'aimerais qu'on reparle un peu
de l'avenir de la nuque il y a quelques
mois Fabien Roussel donc le numéro 1 du
Parti communiste député de votre groupe
également avec cette phrase la nuque et
dépassée et il appelait à aller bien
au-delà de s'adresser à toute la gauche
disait-il sous-entendu bah notamment la
gauche de Bernard Cazeneuve qui est tenu
à l'écart de la Nubie lui-même s'en
tient à l'écart aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec Fabien Roussel
je ferai je partage
l'analyse de Fabien qui est secrétaire
national du Parti communiste français
moi la certitude que j'ai c'est que si
un jour on va avoir dans ce pays une
majorité de gauche un gouvernement
progressiste c'est par se
recroquevillant sur la nuque telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui qu'on arrivera
rassembler donc et bien évidemment il
faut construire une gauche plus large
que celle qu'elle est à condition que ce
soit sur des mesures fortes de
transformation de la société je fais une
différence entre ce que l'on peut porter
au niveau des agressions politiques et
l'action qui est le celle des quatre
groupes à l'Assemblée nationale nous il
est pas question de dire je ne dirai
jamais et ben même si on a des problèmes
de cohésion même si on a des approches
différentes même si on a des votes
différents une culture différente je dis
si on peut travailler ensemble dans le
respect des uns et des autres continuons
à travailler ensemble je ne suis pas de
ceux qui disent il faut casser
l'anus au niveau de la cerve nationale
ce qui ce qui m'intéresse moi c'est ce
qu'on sert inspirer des gens est-ce
qu'on peut est-ce qu'on tient est-ce
qu'on peut répondre aux sollicitations
qu'il y a la grande souffrance qui a
dans le pays j'aimerais savoir un peu
mieux comprendre la situation
aujourd'hui entre les communistes et les
filles parce que les situations est très
tendue entre Fabien Roussel et Jean-Luc
Mélenchon est pas mal de députés elle
est fi est-ce que c'est un problème
personnel entre lui et la France
insoumise ou est-ce que c'est aussi un
problème entre les communistes et la
France insoumise je pense que c'est
c'est un problème d'orientation aussi
politique c'est ce que je disais
auparavant c'est-à-dire que non on pense
que on a la volonté
qui puisse y avoir un gouvernement
progressiste qui puisse avoir un
gouvernement de gauche sur des bases qui
seraient pas les bases de celles qui ont
été mises en œuvre en 2012 et 2017 et
donc dans ce cas là il faut pas
s'enfermer il faut qu'on aille chercher
d'autres progressistes d'autres forces
de gauche et qu'on apparaissent pas
comme étant des repoussoirs parce que si
on apparaît comme étant de repoussoir
d'une part en construira pas c'est
alertif de gauche mais en plus en plus
en alimentera le rassemblement nationale
qui va s'appuyer sur le fait qu'il y a
un rejet de la population par rapport à
des propos qu'on peut tenir donc je
crois que par rapport à ça il y a et
puis il y a aussi une culture politique
différente nous on a cette culture qui
est la culture parlementaire qui est la
culture j'allais dire de d'un parti qui
a été au gouvernement quelquefois par le
passé et qui consiste à prendre les
choses les choses en main de façon
constructive et c'est vrai qu'on a donc
cette différence fondamentale entre la
France insoumise mais quand vous dites
ça ça donne presque l'impression que le
Parti communiste n'est plus un parti
révolutionnaire et que le parti LFI
l'est peut-être devenu Georges Marchais
avait écrit un ouvrage j'étais jeune
militant à l'époque qu'est-ce qui est
révolutionnaire dans la phrase
aujourd'hui par exemple si je vous parle
convergence des luttes je convergence
élu oui pour moi la convergence des
luttes c'est faire en sorte que par
exemple comme on l'avait eu on l'a vécu
pendant le mouvement sur les retraites
que l'on s'appuie sur l'autorisation
syndicales et le fait ce mouvement
s'appuie par exemple sur ce qui se passe
en banlieue pour faire conver ça avec ce
qui se passe avec les soulèvements de la
terre ou avec le mouvement sur les
retraites c'est ce que la France
insoumise a semblé vouloir faire
notamment son organe l'insoumission pour
moi la convergence des lutte c'est pas
ça pour moi la convergence des luttes
c'est s'appuyer sur syndicale quand elle
travaille ensemble comme elles l'ont
fait pour les retraites ça c'est la
convergence et que nous comme politique
on puisse arriver on puisse être un
accompagnement on puisse être un
portefeuille dans d'autres activités
politiques mais c'est pas opposé par
exemple l'activité politique au
mouvement syndical et tenir compte aussi
de tout ce qui se passe dans la société
et analyser ce qui se passe dans la
société essayer de le relayer dans notre
activité politique un mot des élections
européennes pour finir le Parti
communiste à désigner son chef de fil ce
week-end pour les élections européennes
et Léon des fontaines il y aura donc pas
de liste commune avec LFI comme le
souhaitait la France insoumise c'est
défini chef de fil et pas tête de liste
et pas tête de liste donc pour le moment
de chef de fil on a désigné enfin c'est
des communistes qu'il désigneront il y a
eu il y a eu un vote du Conseil national
ensuite
ce qui va se passer c'est sans doute pas
une liste qui sera uniquement une liste
de soldats communistes il y a aussi de
notre de notre côté la volonté d'élargir
cette liste mais pour autant ça veut pas
dire qu'on ira aux élections européennes
forcément avec la France insoumise avec
les écolos d'ailleurs qui volent tout
seul et que les socialistes qui veulent
sans doute aussi donc la porte est pas
totalement fermée merci beaucoup André
chassen vous restez avec nous parce
qu'on va accueillir à présent nos
affranchis et on accueille ce soir
Richard Verdi du média en ligne Suisse
Blic Cécilia gabizon directrice des
rédactions du groupe ettx Magellan et
puis Stéphanie Despierre pour Bourbon
Express bonsoir Stéphanie quelle est
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée et bien
l'histoire du jour c'est l'histoire d'un
lobby qui est sur la sellette cellule
lobby des pesticides en France il
s'appelle fittéis et il réunit à 19
fabricants de produits à phytosanitaires
et il vient d’être rattrapé par la
patrouille c'est une première la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale en
personne a écrit émis en demeure cette
organisme de respecter les obligations à
déontologique des représentants
d'intérêts alors les représentants
d'intérêt c'est le nom français pour
dire lobby avec la loi sapant depuis
2016 la France a tenté de mettre un peu
de transparence dans les contacts entre
les parlementaires les ministres et les
lobbies en tout genre qui tentent
d'inciter
d'influencer l'écriture de la loi alors
c'est lobbies doivent remplir un
registre public tous les ans ils doivent
déclarer sur quel thème ils tentent
d'intervenir combien d'employés sont
dédiés à cette influence comment ils le
font est-ce que c'est par des
discussions informelles avec des députés
des rendez-vous en groupe en tête-à-tête
en leur donnant même des argumentaires
voir on en parle souvent des amendements
prêts à l'emploi alors qu'est-ce qui est
reproché à ce lobby fittéis alors c'est
simple il lui est reproché d'avoir menti
au députés d'avoir donné des chiffres
erronés alors pour comprendre il faut
revenir en arrière en 2018 au moment où
l’assemblée à des pas débat de la loi
egalim la loi sur l'alimentation et
l'agroalimentaire il y a un article dans
cette loi qui prévoit d'interdire
l'exportation des pesticides déjà
interdit en Europe logique me direz-vous
s'ils sont prohibés dans l'Union
européenne pourquoi des entreprises
françaises qui les produisent
pourraient-elles les vendre dans
d'autres pays et bien les fabricants de
pesticides ne l'entendent pas de cette
oreille ici oppose il faut une espèce de
chantage à l'emploi celle le député
socialiste Dominique potier qui nous
raconte la suite
qu'est-ce que vous reprochez à ce lobby
fitalis le gouvernement est troublé les
députés sont troublés par un argument
qui est distillé à l'envie par le lobby
les représentants des intérêts de la
durée phytopharmaceutique qui nous
disent que ça va supprimer plusieurs
milliers d'emplois en France et en
Europe plusieurs années après la mise en
oeuvre de cette loi il n'en est rien
c'est un mensonge nous l'avons dénoncé
pour qu'il ne se reproduisent pas alors
s'il s'agit d'un débat qui a eu lieu en
2018 pourquoi est-ce que on en parle
maintenant c'est pas un peu tard viens
pour deux raisons d'abord parce qu'il
fallait un peu de recul pour voir si ces
chiffres étaient vrais ou faux et puis
surtout il a fallu qu'un député signal
aux autorités de l'Assemblée le
manquement c'est Dominique potier le
député socialiste qu'on vient d'entendre
qu'il a fait il y a quelques mois
c'était seulement en février alors
pourquoi si tard et bien parce que c'est
à ce moment-là qu'il a été contacté par
des associations de défense de
l'environnement qui ont trouvé la faille
juridique pour attaquer le lobby des
pesticides et qui ont donc transmis leur
argumentaire à Dominique Pottier alors
c'est là que c'est cocasse car c'est
donc un lobby oui car les ONG au de la
loi sont des lobbys qui a expliqué un
socialiste comment bien utiliser une loi
socialiste pour contrer oui et alors
cette mise en demeure du lobby va avoir
des conséquences concrètes alors cette
mise en demeure est la sanction la plus
importante prévue par la loi mais en
fait les conséquences sont surtout à
symboliques c'est une sorte de grand
avertissement mais un avertissement
public ce qui n'est jamais bon pour
l'image d'une société dont c'est le
travail de vendre une image d'autres
sociétés donc la défabriquante
pesticides donc futéï sa condamné
fermement à contester fermement toute
négligence volontaire tout mensonge la
société explique que les chiffres
fournis correspondaient un recensement
objectif en novembre 2018 du nombre
d'emplois qui pouvaient être concernés
alors évidemment Clément les ONG de
l'environnement de défense de
transparence ce sont félicités de cette
décision inédite de l'Assemblée
nationale il faut savoir que le Sénat
avait fait pareil pour le même lobby
pour les mêmes raisons il y a un mois
merci beaucoup Stéphanie despierre-andré
Chassaigne sur la question des lobbys
comme ça des lobbys fenêtre qui monte
sur les chiffres pour influencer les
députés ça arrive souvent ou je découvre
je découvre autant que je travaille
beaucoup sur cette question des
pesticides j'ai pas été approché je fais
actuellement un rapport d'ailleurs dans
le cas de la commission des affaires
européennes de l'Assemblée sur les plans
stratégique nationaux et on s'intéresse
à la question des pesticides je
connaissais pas ce cet organisme mais
c'est vrai qu'on a des contacts
notamment vous l'avez dit avec les ONG
désolé
Dominique potier on travaille tous les
deux beaucoup sur des notamment sur les
questions de l'agroécologie sur laquelle
sur la question du foncier agricole et
on a des des rendez-vous avec avec des
ONG qui nous expliquent leur point de
vue et s'il y a des entreprises à
rencontrer on n'est pas opposé non plus
à échanger avec des entreprises
quelquefois ça peut se faire d'ailleurs
par le biais de ce qu'on peut appeler
des lobbies mais ça se fait de façon de
façon correcte avec une écoute et et de
façon j'allais dire publique où on peut
avoir des auditions pour connaître
bien sûr bien sûr et bien sûr il y a
peut-être certains députés un peu plus
fragiles qui peuvent se laisser
embarquer par ça mais c'est extrêmement
contrôlé merci à vous on passe à vous
Richard Verly vous vouliez revenir
Richard sur l'impact des émeutes des
violences urbaines françaises à
l'étranger on sait qu'Emmanuel Macron a
dû annuler sa visite d'État en Allemagne
alors est-ce que c'est grave docteur
c'est grave et pas seulement pour la
France c'est cela qui est le plus
intéressant quand on lit les
commentaires de la presse internationale
sur les émeutes et les violences
urbaines car tout le monde au fond en
Europe notamment se pose la même
question et si cette bouffée de violence
déferlée aussi chez nous les seuls à
renvoyer la France à ses démons auront
été et ce n'est pas une surprise les
premiers ministres polonais et hongrois
avec lesquels Emmanuel Macron ferrailler
encore à Bruxelles sur l'immigration
vendredi dernier lors du sommet européen
avant qu'il ne revienne rapidement à
Paris depuis Varsovie Matteo soravieki y
est même allé de son tweet vidéo
montrant des scènes bucoliques tournées
dans son pays entrecoupés de voitures
incendiées et de vitrines fra passer en
France a beaucoup de poignards entre
membres de l'Union européenne à remettre
qu'il est vrai dans le contexte de la
dénonciation par Paris des atteintes à
l'état de droit dans ces deux pays de
l'Est les remarques les plus
intéressantes sont venus d'Allemagne et
du Royaume-Uni ou après les
traditionnelles avertissements ou
ressortissants les deux gouvernements
ont admis que si ceux qui se passe en
France interrogent aussi leur société et
leur jeunesse exemple à Londres où les
éditorialistes pointent du doigt le
système judiciaire britannique l'échec
des courtes peines qui ne parviennent
plus à remettre les jeunes dans le droit
chemin à Berlin c'est plutôt l'engrenage
politique français qui attire
l'attention car plus l'extrême droite
progresse dans l'Hexagone plus l'AFD en
Allemagne a du grain à moudre ça veut
dire qu'on en gros on voit la France
comme un laboratoire de ce qui ne marche
pas effectivement c'est un peu ça
surtout du côté des États-Unis où la
crise des banlieues est une fois de plus
vue sous l'angle des problèmes ratio et
communautaires à force d'ignorer ses
minorités de les discriminer selon la
presse américaine la France voit ses
quartiers exploser comme de l'autre côté
de l'Atlantique alors je n'ai pas senti
toutefois tout au cette semaine de
violence la moindre satisfaction devant
cette explosion française alors vous
savez en allemand il y a ce mot
shaddonfroy 2 on se réjouit du malheur
des autres et bien non il faut savoir
qu'en Suisse à Lausanne en Belgique à
Bruxelles des heures ont aussi opposé
les jeunes à la police chacun baisse la
tête avec une différence néanmoins tous
les voisins de la France juste
problématique la répression policière et
la violence d'État qui est à l'oeuvre il
y a peut-on lire partout un problème
avec la police française c'est ce que
dit aussi l'ONU c'est ce chantier que
les observateurs étrangers de la France
estiment urgent d'ouvrir pas sur
qu'Emmanuel Macron et Gérald Darmanin
soit sur la même longueur d'onde Merci à
VOUS Richard Verly on passe à vous
Cécilia gabizon bonsoir vous êtes
directrice des rédactions ETX Magellan
et ce soir vous revenez sur la décision
de la Cour suprême des États-Unis qui
vient de supprimer la discrimination
positive dans les universités
américaines oui et ça rapporte avec ce
que vous ce dont vous venez de parler
parce que quelque part pourquoi est-ce
que ça nous intéresse cette histoire
donc il y avait une association
fondée par un caca de conservateur qui
au nom de l'inégalité entre les
étudiants et notamment les étudiants
asiatiques qui seraient défavorisées
dans l'accès aux universités américaines
en fait avait porté ça devant la Cour
suprême qui a déterminé que désormais on
arrêterait la discrimination positive
c'est-à-dire en gros de créer un canal
prioritaire pour les étudiants
afro-américains pourquoi ça nous
intéresse nous en France ça nous
intéresse parce que quelque part il y a
de nombreuses voix et beaucoup avec
plein de bonnes intentions qui
voudraient s'inspirer du système
américain et d'une forme de
racialisation de la société de lecture
et d'une forme de ces politiques de
compensation alors je reviens sur le cas
américain si vous voulez bien c'est que
aux Etats-Unis évidemment on a à la fois
les maîtres et les descendants des
maîtres et les descendants des esclaves
qui vivent ensemble dans le même pays
c'est une société qui pratiquement des
sa fondation irascialisée le premier
recensement en 1790 je crois fait déjà
été en fait sépare les gens en race et
200 ans plus tard on se retrouve avec la
même chose mais cette fois-ci de manière
déclarative quand finalement la
ségrégation et c'était en 1964 il y a
pas si longtemps s'arrête on crée cette
politique d'affirmative action de
discrimination positive et qui en fait
quelque part une forme de compensation
avec au départ des quotas qui sont
d'ailleurs très vite écartés est-ce que
c'est politique d'affirmative action
elles ont fonctionné elles ont produit
des résultats aux États-Unis oh on
dirait oui et non oui le nombre
d'étudiants afro descendant évidemment
augmenter parce qu'on en avait pas donc
très fortement augmenté mais en fait
sans changer la dynamique globale
c'est-à-dire que les retards n'ont pas
été il y a une information d'une petite
élite bourgeoise noire mais la plupart
des Afro-Américains connaissent des
difficultés sociales extrêmement
importantes des taux de pauvreté très
très supérieures à toutes les autres
communautés et globalement ce qu'on peut
dire et on l'a vu avec les assassinats
littéralement de noir dans la rue et le
mouvement Black lives matters c'est que
dans le fond et sans globaliser parce
que c'est des sujets toujours très
compliqué
cette lecture de compensation fondée sur
le système de l'oppresseur qui était les
blancs contre les noirs on a repris ses
catégories pour faire des compensations
mais en fait on n'a pas attaqué le je
dirais les fondements du mal et les
fondements de la réconciliation et donc
ça n'a pas finalement réconcilié la
société américaine merci beaucoup
Cécilia merci à vous non quand même sur
la société française aujourd'hui nous on
se dit finalement qu'est-ce qu'on peut
apprendre de ça on peut pas dire que
c'était un échec mais ceux qui pensent
qu'en établissant en fait de la
racialisation et des quotas et et en
fait en créant des politiques qui
quelque part vont par budget on est
toujours le différent de quelqu'un on
sera jamais en fait c'est quotas
et donc je rejette le mot race
d'ailleurs mon groupe parlementaire est
fait voter il y a quelques années une
proposition de loi qui n'est pas allée
plus loin malheureusement pour enlever
le mot race de tous les textes qui sont
les textes législatifs de notre pays
parce qu'il y a pas plusieurs races il y
a la race humaine et le reste c'est des
questions de le relégation sociale c'est
pas des questions radicales opposer la
discrimination positive si j'ai bien
compris merci beaucoup à tous les trois
nous affranchis et à vous André
chassaine d'être venu sur notre plateau
d'en savoir garde c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui vous retrouverez Myriam en
Kawa demain d'ici là portez-vous bien
[Musique]